merci beaucoup à son arrivée sur
l'exploitation après quelques serrage de
mains et les formules de politesses
d'usagé
le ton est donné mais je vais vous dire
ce qui se passera par là franchement
pourquoi les français ne respectent plus
les hommes politiques parce qu'ils
servent à rien nicolas dupont aignan se
pose en candidat du changement il veut
garantir le prix du lait ou encore
remettre les quotas par pays
un discours forcément apprécié et
entendu par certains agriculteurs je
fais pas partie son parti politique je
suis à dr à aucun parti politique mais
je pense qu'on a besoin d'un homme
sincère
la france a besoin d'un homme fort et
d'un homme sincère fait que soit le
parti je pense qu'il a appris quelque
chose parce que on a parlé des boutons
et ça je pense que c'était et
connaissait pas vraiment là commerce et
john charles est très intéressant de
recevoir pour deux pour les montrer
notre métier ou vraiment d'autres
métiers l'objectif du candidat à
l'élection présidentielle 2017 à
ratisser plus large tout en souhaitant
avoir une position centrale
oui je dis il faut sauver la france
alors après il s'agit pas de se prendre
pour le christ l'a rassuré vous mais il
s'agit à un moment de réveiller nos
concitoyens et de leur dire on peut
mener une autre politique
un homme politique doit pas à vivre hors
sol je pense que la cause de nos
malheurs
c'est une classe politiques n'écoutent
plus et qui est coupé des réalités
or pour ne pas être coupé des réalités
il faut parcourir la france
le chef du parti debout la france en
profite pour semer la bonne parole aussi
grâce à la sortie de son livre
après une séance de dédicaces à chalon
réunion publique prévue ce soir à
corbigny le marathon pour sa campagne
présidentielle ne fait que commencer
allez suivant bonjour